a veces cuando tratamos de sintetizar
una molécula tenemos que usar un grupo
protector en este vídeo hablaremos sobre
cómo podemos proteger alcoholes usando
un grupo trial kills y lilo digamos que
nuestro objetivo es obtener este
compuesto de la derecha a partir del
compuesto de la izquierda tal vez estén
pensando en que este compuesto órgano
metálico puede funcionar como núcleo
filo porque este carbono tiene una carga
formal negativa así que un par de
electrones podría atacar a este carbono
que es parcialmente positivo y así estos
electrones se irían junto con el bromo
con lo que podríamos agregar este
carbono y este para formar nuestro
compuesto deseado pero
desafortunadamente no es así como la
reacción ocurre porque nuestro órgano
litio
además de ser un núcleo filo fuerte
también es una base fuerte lo que
realmente ocurre es que un par de
electrones funciona como base y toma
este protón dejando estos electrones en
el oxígeno para formar un arco óxido
entonces no formaremos este producto en
realidad formaremos un producto en el
que nuestro oxígeno tiene tres pares de
electrones libres lo que le da una carga
formal negativa y también tenemos un ión
de litio por eso es tan importante usar
un grupo protector necesitamos proteger
este grupo hidroxilo para evitar que
reaccione si de alguna manera podemos
proteger el grupo esta parte de la
molécula podrá reaccionar y luego
podemos quitar el grupo protector para
así obtener nuestro compuesto deseado
esa es la idea veamos cómo podemos usar
un grupo protector aquí del lado derecho
tenemos cloruro de permitir dimetil si
lo tenemos un grupo de butilo dos grupos
metilo y un cloro unidos a un silicio
por eso se llama cloruro de termita
dimetil si lee lo que se puede abreviar
como tv tm scl y observen que este
silicio está unido a un carbono un
carbono un carbono y un cloro todos
ellos son más electro negativos que el
silicio le quitarán densidad electrónica
así que nuestro silicio es parcialmente
positivo y puede funcionar como electro
filo entonces este alcohol funcionará
como núcleo filo
un par de electrones atacará a nuestro
silicio empujando a estos electrones
hacia el cloro y así nuestro imida sol
nos ayudará a perder
hcl claro el mecanismo es más complicado
de lo que yo les muestro pero esta es
una forma de entenderlo entonces tenemos
un núcleo filo y un electro filo y
colocaremos el grupo protector en
nuestro alcohol dibujemos el producto
ahora tenemos nuestro oxígeno unido al
silicio con dos pares de electrones
libres el silicio está unido a dos
grupos metilo y un grupo tribu tilo otra
forma en que pueden encontrar esto es
con el oxígeno unido a nuestro grupo
protector escrito como tb de ms así no
tenemos que dibujarlo todo ahora ya que
agregamos el grupo protector podemos
hacer la reacción con el compuesto
órgano metálico
vamos a dibujarlo aquí tenemos el carbón
que funcionará como núcleo filo así que
un par de electrones atacará a este
carbono empujando estos electrones que
se irán junto con el bromo dibujemos lo
que nos queda
hemos agregado un triple enlace justo
aquí este carbono corresponde a este
carbono y este carbono es este carbono
así que estos electrones formaron este
enlace y aún tenemos a nuestro grupo
protector el silicio con dos grupos
metilo y un grupo de butilo ahí está
entonces una vez que la reacción ocurre
podemos quitar el grupo protector para
formar nuestro compuesto deseado así que
necesitamos algo que pueda reaccionar
con nuestro silicio y para eso usaremos
fluoruro de tetra but in amonio que es
una fuente de aniones fluoruro tenemos
el flúor con sus pares de electrones
libres y una carga forma al negativo
funcionará como núcleo filo aunque es un
núcleo filo débil y solo atacará al
silicio les explicaré por qué el silicio
está unido a varios carbonos pero el
silicio es más grande que el carbono así
que los enlaces carbono silicio son más
largos eso significa que hay menor
impedimento estético por lo tanto el
silicio está más expuesto para que elaño
fluoruro pueda atacarlo otro factor
importante es que el silicio tiene
orbitales de disponibles entonces
dibujemos lo que nos queda después de
que el flúor ataca a nuestro silicio
ahora tenemos un intermediario en donde
el silicio está unido al flúor pero
también está unido a dos grupos metilo y
a un grupo tribu tilo todo esto le da al
silicio una carga formal negativa quizá
les parece raro que el silicio tenga 5
enlaces pero no hay problema porque
tiene esos orbitales de otra razón por
la que el flúor puede atacar al silicio
es porque el enlace que se forma entre
el flúor y el silicio es muy fuerte
finalmente podemos regresar estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno y
necesitaremos protones así
reformamos el alcohol
hemos formado nuestro producto y también
tenemos flúor unido a nuestro silicio
entonces logramos quitar el grupo
protector y formamos nuestro compuesto
deseado esa es la idea de usar un grupo
protector nos permite proteger una parte
de la molécula para que la reacción solo
ocurra en otra parte además es fácil
poder quitarlo para finalmente obtener
nuestro compuesto deseado